well let's have a look back now at the
key events over the last six months our
defense and security analyst michael
clark is at the screen for us michael to
take us through the last six months yes
kimberly um after months of denials from
putin to everybody who visited the
kremlin that there was no invasion
planned on the 24th of february exactly
six months ago today the invasion took
place uh invaded from several places at
once from belarus and from russia proper
with air attacks all around
the country and that invasion was meant
to be all over uh within three days and
completed by the uh the eighth of march
um on the 28th of february we saw this
big convoy developing uh out of belarus
down towards kiev and we all assumed
that this was going to be the circ the
encirclement of kiev which indeed it was
intended to be didn't work the convoy
just ran out of momentum the ukrainians
attacked it or attacked the logistics it
was one of the great humiliations for
the russian military that they couldn't
run a big convoy to do anything however
they did take cursion they didn't
conquer cursion it was given to them by
internal subversion so the russians just
moved in on that city it's the biggest
city that russia has occupied in the
whole of the country it's an important
city because it controls uh access into
the crimea and the water supply almost
immediately civil disturbances civil
disobedience developed incursion people
turning out on the streets making clear
what they thought about the russians the
russians didn't really know how to
handle this at the time they were very
passive
since then of course it's become a much
darker picture the russians have become
far more repressive and these
demonstrations public demonstrations
have now turned into a partisan warfare
of assassinations and car bombings and
so on which the russians of course say
is terrorism meanwhile the russians had
to withdraw from kiev the ukrainians
were moving into the suburbs places like
butcher that had been uh intensively
fought over and all the war crimes
became clear not just in butcher but in
chernov
further
northeast those war crimes shocked the
world and all the leaders who have been
to ukraine have commented on what they
saw in butcher um meanwhile uh mario
paul mario paul should have fallen in
the first days of the conflict it was so
close to the front line but it didn't
and mario paul held out for a long time
in april the russians
said that they were going to concentrate
on the donbass they took khaki
but then had to give it up
and the ukrainians were able to liberate
kharkiv and the russians are now still a
good 25 kilometers away that offensive
hasn't gone much further for the
ukrainians but they've they've kept
kharkiv as a the second city which is in
ukrainian hands although it is still
subject to uh missile attacks fairly
regularly but mariappal finally having
held out from the end of february right
through to the almost the end of may
finally fell on the 21st of may of
course the house of style steelworks was
the final uh holding place of holding
out uh and when that fell and mario pole
defenders were taken into captivity that
strategically that didn't matter so much
but emotionally it was a big moment and
the russians put an enormous effort into
finally taking mario paul because in
fact they needed to move their troops
north to get on with this uh offensive
across the donbass and so this donbass
offensive has been going on since june
on the 24th of june they were able to
take severe don yet quite an important
um regional city and then very quickly
best thing they've done so far
militarily was take liciansk and by
crossing the river
they were able then to hold on to get
hold of luhansk the the one of the two
uh oblasts the two regions in the
donbass that gives them about a
two-thirds of the donbass but not the
final third they need all of the donbass
if they can say that they've conquered
it and they need some of the material
and the resources of that other part of
the donbass but their offensive has run
out of steam they've just gone nowhere
in the last two or three weeks because
they've been transferring troops down to
the southwest because the ukrainians ran
kirshan in the southwest are preparing a
big offensive to try to take kersham
back
both sides now know that the weather
will change in the next two or three
months couple of months by the end of
october early november they know that
winter is coming and both of them for
different reasons have got some pretty
big decisions to make as the winter
comes on the russians to actually make
something of their donbass offensive the
ukrainians to try to seize back cursion
which will be a very important
psychological blow to them if they're
able to do it so for both sides and for
different reasons winter is coming